Kim is going to start us off in Boise
Idaho Boise Idaho hi Kim how are you I'm
great Dave how are you doing better than
I deserve what's up well I am calling
because my husband and I are drowning in
debt and I wondered if I might be able
to get it Dave Ramsey lifeline thrown to
us how much done if you got cut oh well
we have about a hundred and fifty two
thousand that is not including our house
and my husband makes about 150 thousand
income a year and I'm a stay-at-home mom
and we have what is what is the hundred
and fifty two thousand dollars of debt
what kind of debt is it mm-hmm
it is about ninety thousand in credit
card more and about sixty two thousand
and a variety of things like a 403b loan
and that were paying back to ourselves
through my husband's employer what's
left over a second mortgage on a short
sale that we had that's about thirty two
thousand we pay monthly on that about
two hundred and forty five a month an
old medical bill loans for my parents
car loans and one car yes how much you
owe on the car we owe about thirty five
hundred on it 30 times thank you yeah
it's six eighty a month and my question
has to do with whether the cars may be
worth according to Kelley Blue Book
about fifteen thousand and we still owe
the thirty-five hundred and if we were
to try to sell that would it be best to
sell that and then just try to get
something that's a lot cheaper and
what's not really a problem I mean it
solves a part of your problem you got
one hundred fifty two thousand dollars
in debt fifteen thousand dollars then to
solve the problem no not major problems
what the crap have y'all been buying on
credit cards ninety thousand bucks um I
don't know it's just a capital D um
decision so okay all right I'll go with
that
just anything furniture a car that we
didn't need a trailer that we sold a
camping trailer you're a few years back
so you guys are acting like you're in
Congress you're just buying everything
in sight yeah I know it's totally stupid
$150,000 you and you're completely broke
yes is your house with me it's about
eight seventeen hundred seventeen fifty
a month something like that okay well I
think what's going on is you guys are
spending about two hundred thousand
dollars a year and you're making about
150 and you've been doing it for quite a
while oh yeah and so just this there's
no boundaries and the disorganization
it's just eating your lunch in it
apparently the car is a minor portion of
it it's ten percent of the issue not not
ninety percent of the problem of the
vast majority this is credit card debt
and bat and bad decision on short sale
and that kind of thing is your credit
destroyed no as well it's not destroyed
but it is we were able to buy a house
about a year ago which was you know
probably a dumb decision but that's
before I yeah kappa yeah probably is but
it's again it's not your problem though
your problem is you guys are spending
like your out-of-control spending and so
what we've got to do is we gotta get you
guys on a plan we got you and your
husband look at this and say this is a
major freakin problem and we have to do
major major major change we are not
allowed to see a restaurant in the next
24 months unless you're there working
yeah you're not going on vacation in the
next 24 months maybe with the reasons
you're not saying anything except food
and lights and water and not a lot of
that you're not buying any more clothes
God knows you have enough you following
me I am this is what you've got to do
you got to go to scorched earth and both
of you have to commit to doing that
because you're heading headlong into
bankruptcy one bump in the road this
thing's going to explode
mmm-hmm you're right alone with nitro in
the backseat okay well we actually have
your book and my husband's read it I
just picked it up about a week and a
half ago and I have about ten things on
Craigslist right now that's good okay so
you're getting started how's your house
are you feeling about it oh it's like
well you don't need to sell that one
particular item you know keep it we
might need it and I'm thinking I haven't
ever used it why do I need it so have
you done a rotten budget together yet
no we haven't what we did discuss it a
few nights ago so at least we're looking
in the direct here's what I'm going to
tell you you can fix this mess the bad
news is you're in a deep hole the good
news is you got a really good shovel you
got a good income versus the amount of
money you owe so you can fix this mess
but you cannot fix this mess and play
with this you have to get unbelievably
crazy mad about this and you and your
husband lock arms and say we have cancer
in our wallet we're going to fight this
together like we're fighting cancer and
you have got to get unbelievably angry
and passionate and tear into this and
change your habits dramatically for the
rest of your life but certainly for the
next 24 to 36 months if you will do that
you can clean this mess up it's going to
probably lead you to sell this car it's
probably going to lead you to do a lot
of things that are going to be very very
painful and they're all going to be
worth it if you get the mess cleaned up
lastly I think you could probably borrow
a little money like ten or fifteen
thousand dollars and offer that $32,000
second there was a settlement offer from
a settlement of ten thousand dollars
they'll probably take it if they'll take
it then go borrow the money and give
them ten thousand bucks and that lowers
your debt by 20 grand right there but
you've got to get some very serious
things going on I want you to to go
through Financial Peace University our
nine week class I'm going to pay for it
hold on I'll sign you up
you